when we look at all of the living
diversity around us then a natural
question is well how related are the
different species to each other and if
you put that into an evolutionary
context relatedness should be tied to
how recent did two species share a
common ancestor and what we're going to
try to do in this video is construct a
tree for showing how different species
evolved from common ancestors and we're
going to do it based on some of these
observable traits that we see but this
is going to be a huge oversimplification
i'm only doing it with five species and
five very simple traits as we'll see or
as we'll talk about in future videos
this can be done in a much more complex
way and that's what biologists would do
they would look at much more than five
traits
and they would look at
molecular evidence molecular evidence in
terms of protein differences in terms of
dna differences to really start to build
out what we call a phylogenetic tree so
let me write this down that's what we're
going to create
phyllo
genetic
tree
phylo comes from the greek for
group or kind or tribe and then genetic
comes
related to the word genesis
how do these things come about how do
the different groups or tribes or in
this case how do the different species
come about
well when you're trying to make one of
these trees it's important to realize
that this is a hypothesis but you're
like always trying to come up with the
simplest hypothesis that can explain the
observations that you actually see
and when we look at these at least the
species that we have listed here it
looks like there's one that is more
different than all the other ones the
lamprey here does not have any of these
five traits that we are observing so
this we would call the out group
the lamprey
is the out group and a lot of times when
you need to construct a phylogenetic
tree they might provide you something
with something that is clearly an out
group here it doesn't have any of these
observable traits
sometimes if we're looking at genetic
differences it might have the largest
number of
genetic differences relative to
everything else and so
it makes sense the the simplest
hypothesis is its common ancestor is
most distant into the past with
everything else and so let me start to
draw this tree
so
i'm going to put
deep into the past
so
deep into the past there is a branching
out point
where you have the common ancestor of
the lamprey and everything else we see
here
so eventually you that common ancestor
and there's many many species along the
way and eventually we get
we get a lamprey in present time
in present time
and so the next thing to think about is
all right well how did everything else
end up branching
well what's what's common about
everything else that maybe wasn't common
about the lamprey well one common thing
is we see that everything else at least
that we have listed here have have jaws
and so it's reasonable to say all right
we have this common ancestor this
between the lamprey and everything else
at this branching point right over here
and then it branched off into multiple
species and one of those species must
have evolved jaws so let me put jaws
right over here
so
jaws right over there and jaws that's
called jaws are considered a derived
trait this in ancestral species at this
root did not have jaws were assuming but
at some point they evolved and they
stuck around
because they proved to be favorable in
certain environments or it could have
even been things like genetic drift who
knows but i'm guessing that it was
favorable in certain environments so
let's see let's see if we can classify
everyone else so now out of the four so
we've let's actually cross out the
lamprey just for simplification since
we've already classified that character
now of everyone else we've already
thought about everyone's got jaws so now
let's go to the next most common trait
so and actually let me cross out the
jaws too just for
keep things simple so i can do that a
little bit
cleaner
so i'm going to cross out the jaws
and now let's see the most the next most
common trait is are the lungs but not
every species that we have left has
lungs the sea bass does not have lungs
it does not breathe air the way that the
animals that live outside of the water
breathe air and so they the the next the
next point of divergence must be between
the sea bass and everything that we have
left over so let me draw that
so
once again i said must be this is a
hypothesis i think it's a reasonable
hypothesis
so let me draw that
so
this is the
c
c bass
and there's a common ancestor between
the sea bass and everything else in the
antelope the bald eagle and the
alligator and at some point that common
ancestor diverged into multiple species
and one of those one of those child
species must have evolved lungs so lungs
must have evolved at some point
but we're assuming that that wasn't that
wasn't on this lineage for the sea bass
and once again i'm just trying to find
the simplest explanation there might
have been some situation where maybe
lungs evolved and then d or then went
away at some point you rever you
reverted to an ancestral form but we
like to go with the simplest explanation
this is a property that biologists also
often called
parsimony and actually let me write this
down parsimony which in everyday
language means cheap if someone tells
you you're parsimonious it's a nice
sounding word but it means that you are
cheap
but parsimony in this context say hey
we're trying to we're trying to be cheap
with com with complexity we're trying to
be as simple as possible in our
explanation of what's going on but
anyway let's go back to what we were
doing so we've already put into
consideration we have already talked
about the sea bass here and we have
already talked about lungs
all right so what do we have left so we
have to talk about the antelope the bald
eagle the alligator and gizzards and fur
all right it looks like the bald eagle
and alligator have a gizzard the
antelope has fur oh and actually we
haven't talked about the bald eagle and
feathers as yet either
all right so it is possible so let's
make the next thing
between
well we could do it we could do it this
way and once again i'm trying to do this
in real time something that seems
so let's
let's make a branch here
and let's say that that is the branch
for
let's say that's the branch for the bald
eagle i'll say b eagle
that's the branch for the bald eagle
let's see if i can construct one that
will explain the differences between the
bald eagle the antelope and the
alligator well the bald eagle and the
alligator have something in common they
have a gizzard in common so let me make
a branching point make them a little bit
closer than the bald eagle is to the
antelope
so let me do that
so
let me put the alligator there
and then i'm going to talk about when we
get these derived traits so that is
the alligator and obviously i could have
written the alligator on this side in
the bald eagle on that that i could have
rotated i could rotate at any one of
these branching points and then what we
would have left is the antelope and
let's see if i can account for all of
these derived traits
antelope
all right so we have the common ancestor
of the sea bass the bald eagle the
alligator of the antelope right over
here we have a branching point at some
point the lungs where we are
hypothesizing evolve in this branch
and then this branch well let's say that
this branch this is the common ancestor
between the antelope alligator and bald
eagle and a common ancestor of the bald
eagle and alligator they have to they
have to get the gizzard so let's put the
gizzard down
right over here this is where the
gizzard this is our hypothesis
we're doing that same colors
so
that's the gizzard
gizzard
right over there and so everything after
everything that descended from that
ancestor that had the gizzard well
they're going to have gizzards that's
what we're assuming but once again that
can be lost this is a this is a
hypothesis
and so we have accounted for the gizzard
let me
let me cross that out
so we have accounted for the gizzard and
so let's see we have to account for the
feathers and the bald eagle is the only
one that has feathers so let me put that
here so at some point you have a common
ancestor of an alligator and a bald
eagle it branches off into multiple
species one of which one of which gets a
feather or gets feathers
and once again i'm you know that could
have branched off into many many things
because we know that the bald eagle
isn't the only species with feathers but
the bald eagle for sure is a species
that has feathers and let's see so we've
accounted for the feathers now
feathers and now we just have to account
for the fur the fur of the antelope and
so we don't know where this could have
happened we might want to look for more
evidence to come up with a good
hypothesis but someplace along this
right branch we could put
we could put the fur
and so there you have it this is
actually a reasonable phylogenetic tree
i i practiced the part the biological i
the the practice of parsimony to come up
with the simplest explanation but there
are more complicated explanations and we
don't know some of those more
complicated explanations could very well
be true
but from this we have a very quick and
easy graphical representation of how
related different species could be and
where they share common ancestors so
bald eagle and an alligator based on
this phylogenetic tree we would say are
more related than a bald eagle is to an
antelope they have a they have a more
the bald eagle and the alligator have a
more common common ancestor or more
recent common ancestor right there than
both of their common ancestors with the
antelope and that would make them more
related and if we were doing this for
real we would want to look at genetic
evidence and and look at the various
proteins and say okay do we do does that
back this up are bald eagle and
alligators dna do they have more in
common with each other than they do with
the dna say of an antelope
and many for especially once you get
complex there could be many different
explanations and we just want to get
more and more and more evidence to keep
refining our phylogenetic trees